the jurogan experience it's so funny to
me how people just get so caught up in
east coast and west coast because it
really only happened in rap
it never happened with rock and roll
right you know it never happened with
sports i mean it did a little bit with
sports in some teams but
with the big thing with with rap music
was always
east coast versus west coast until you
guys came around right
yeah i'm like really familiar
with with that beef um i wrote about it
in my book
of uh how me and puffy
you know had a meeting and
uh they wanted me to mediate a meeting
with him and sugg
was concerned you know with that was
after
tupac and all of these people you know
had got killed
and uh it was something that i wanted to
do but i couldn't really get
you know uh between it because
you know things just didn't add up
properly and i don't believe in
stepping in between something when i
don't have all the information
um yeah that's got to be extremely
difficult right you were in the middle
of like a legitimate
war where two of the all-time greats
yeah were murdered yeah i was asked to
uh
be in the middle of it and and uh
after tupac was murdered
one of the things i done was i heard
puffy and biggie was
in la shooting a video so i was on my
tour bus and i turned it all the way
around i think i was close to phoenix
and i turned it around just to go and
have a conversation with big and puffy
to
alert them that they were in a place
that i didn't feel
that they should have been in and you
know i went there and had a conversation
with both of them just to kind of put
them on notice that
you know this ain't the place to be
right now that was before biggie was
killed yeah
how long before it was i think a few
weeks
i think a few weeks before and uh
you know sometimes and i know puffy
meant well and i know
biggie meanwhile sometimes a lot of
individuals are
what i call surface deep where the
streets are concerned which
simply mean you don't you understand
them to
a certain depth you know what i mean but
i understood that that wasn't
definitely la that wasn't a good place
to be because my ears was to the street
and you know i just wanted to echo it it
was on my spirit to
to let them know and i did and uh
unfortunately you know it didn't save
him but
everybody can learn from those mistakes
moving forward
yeah it's a devastating loss the
both of them yeah i mean what they left
behind
you know to this day yeah if you got a
mount rushmore of hip-hop those two
dudes are on there
right there's no no doubt about it oh
yeah two brilliant guys
brilliant yeah there's a video of biggie
on the street that i watch all the time
when he was 17 years old st
piece of paper in his hand with his
lyrics yeah wrapping his ass off
17 years old yeah it's incredible when
you watch the video you're like
what talent yeah what power that dude
had
catch new episodes of the joe rogan
experience for free only on spotify
watch back catalog jre videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly
switch between video and audio
experience on spotify
you can listen to the jre in the
background while using other apps and
can download episodes to save on data
cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre episodes
you just need to search for the jre on
your spotify app
go to spotify now to get this full
episode
of the joe rogan experience